Bonjour à tous
Déjà j'ai un nouveau micro
Bien radiophonique pour avoir un son absolument parfait
Skyrock premier sur le rap empoche un max de pognon avec la skyroulette
Aujourd'hui je me suis rendu compte que ça fait presque 6 ans jour pour jour
que j'ai créé ma chaîne Youtube :
Norman fait des vidéos
J'avais envie de marquer le coup en faisant un truc un peu spécial
Donc je voulais revivre mes premières vidéos avec vous, réagir un peu à tout ça
Bref voyons un peu tout ça ensemble, LET'S GO
On replonge dans mes anciennes vidéos
Ma toute première vidéo date de ....
Voilà, je suis totalement vieux
Les pirates de Facebook
Aiéé, je me suis fait pirater mon compte Facebook
Non je suis content
Attends est-ce qu'on peut déjà parler de cette entrée en matière ?
Aiéé, je me suis fait pirater mon compte Facebook
Alors vraiment au début de mes vidéos j'avais toujours le même réflexe nul de toujours faire "hunn"
Je ne sais pas pourquoi, c'était vraiment un sorte de toc de personnage que je me suis inventé
Qui est nul à chier
Bonsoir hunn ah c'est parti on commence une nouvelle vidéo hunn
Enfin je veux dire moi hunn
Euh là je l'ai refait à nouveau
*Hunn*
Dislike
Non mais n'importe quoi j'ai oublié cette vidéo quoi
Chat dans toilettes
Les vidéos les plus populaires du web c'est les vidéos...
J'en ai marre de moi qui parle franchement
Arrêtez de me battre au collège s'il vous plaît
Pour filmer votre chat il faut une qualité d'image absolument dégueulasse
Alors pour ça je vous conseille d'utiliser un téléphone portable
J'avais un Nokia N95
J'ai l'impression que ça date d'un autre siècle
Ca y est je me suis enfin décidé pour la première fois de l'année à aller faire du...
C'est quoi ce bonnet ?
C'est bien ça, c'est un cache-col
Je portais donc un cache-col que j'ai mis sur ma tête tel un bonnet
Cette merde Queshua sur la tête
Toute votre vie...huun
Ah, je l'ai refait !
Putain mais j'avais combien d'articles ? 3 ! Heureusement qu'il m'a filé un panneau !
Aucun rire dans la salle !
J'avais oublié cette vidéo: "L'été c'est sexy"
Ce titre n'a aucun sens
Bah, nous les mecs on sait plus que ça existe les mini-jupes, les décolletés...
La blague de puceau à 1000% quoi..
Ohlala, on avait oublié les seins des filles
Bon, on a fait un peu le tour de mes vidéos sur YouTube. C'était plutôt sympathique
Mais je pense, qu'il est tant de passer aux choses sérieuses
On va regarder mes vidéos d'avant YouTube
Mes vidéos de Dailymotion
Est-ce que je me rappelle de mon mot de passe ?
"je déteste hugotoutseul"
Ah ! C'est bon ça fonctionne !
Je faisais des vidéos avec Hugo et Marc
Et...au tout début c'était qu'avec Hugo
Ouuuh
2,7 mille abonnés
c'est quoi heuh .. Plein les yeux
Monsieur est un homme tout a fait banal
On a une video qui s'appelle le PIPI
tout simplement
Attention humour subtile
p*tain ... j'ai honte
je comprend maintenant avec le temps pourquoi
ces videos n'avaient pas vraiment de succès
Ah j'avais oublié celle-là. La fin du monde
Oui, oui, oui le 21 décembre 2012 ça me va ouais
Ah non mec, le 21 décembre 2012 tu peux pas
Pourquoi?
C'est la fin du monde!
Pourquoi sur toutes les prises on dirait que Cyprien va se taper une énorme barre
On dirait à chaque fois qu'il est comme ça
Kiwi est mon maitre !
Ha ! Ha oui ! Kiwi est mon maître ! Pourquoi je dis ça ?
A l'époque je ne m'appelais pas Norman
Je m'apelais Cowboy et Hugo s'appelait Kiwi !
Ohlalala... Je viens de voir un truc qui vient de me faire très très mal...
Je viens de voir écrit sous ma vidéo : il y a 9 ans !
*SONNETTE* Ha ! Apparemment on a un invité !
Bonjour ! Mesdames et Messieurs : Hugo tout seul !
Hé ! On est amis depuis combien de temps ?
On est amis depuis.. 2005 ! Donc ça fait 13 ans ! C'est beau !
Et on n'est plus amis depuis ..?
Heu 4 ans !
Merci Hugo d'être présent dans ma vidéo !
Hé bien merci les amis ça va ?
Merci d'être venu !
Donc on va regarder mes anciennes vidéos, nos anciennes vidéos en l'occurence !
J'ai trop l'impression de regarder tes vidéos là :
"Donc on va regarder mes anciennes vidéos, nos anciennes vidéos !"
Allez on regarde la première officielle ! C'est important
Ohlalala ! Attends.. Nan mais dans celle là je me branle et tout..
Oh la qualité !
Ohlala ! Mais c'est tourné avec la webcam !
Génial !
Donc ça c'est ma première apparition en vidéo sur internet, c'est ça ?
Mon Dieu..
Hugo tu fais quoi ?
Bah je me branle là !
Bon y'a une émotion là quand même !
Oui oui y'a une émotion ! C'est la toute première du Velcrou, sans ça on ne serait pas là !
Alors attends, j'ai trop envie de le revoir ça !
Donc ça c'est une parodie d'une série qui s'appelle Code Lisa
A la webcam, avec iMovie n°1
C'était un kiff parce que j'la kiffait tellement cette série !
J'avais la même coupe, à 100% c'est sûr !
On va regarder un clip qu'on avait fait à l'époque
C'était en l'an 2008
Putain mais c'est quoi ce vieux tee-shirt là ?
Ha mais c'est parce qu'on voulait faire Hip-Hop
Ha oui !
Ohlalala ! C'est une casquette de WoW ça !
Oh "yo yo".. Putain !
Moi c'était la doudoune de ma mère !
Tu t'en rappelles ou pas ?
Les mecs n'avaient vraiment aucun matos quoi !
Ha oui !
Et genre Marc on lui avait dit "viens Hip-Hop"
Et il s'était mis avec un manteau et un pull Celio et un jogging !
Est-ce qu'on parler du style de Kemar ?
Il a mis un haut dandy et un bas de jogging !
C'était tellement nul !
Bon, j'abusais un peu sur le mot négro à l'époque apparemment !
Surtout que tu avais absolument aucun ami noir à cette époque
C'est clair !
Négro ! Des amis que je n'ai pas vraiment !
Heu Next c'est une vidéo qui avait été censurée !
On est des hors la loi !
On regarde Next version zoophile !
Salut et bienvenue dans Next zoophile !
Alors je précise que je n'avais pas le permis de conduire ! Et que je ne l'ai toujours pas d'ailleurs
Et je conduis la caisse de mon père sur 3m
Ouais moi je vais leur montrer que je sais les caresser dans le sens du poil !
Tu peux choisir de rester avec moi ou alors..
De repartir avec ce lecteur TNT !
Lecteur TNT mon gars !
C'est très mignon, moi j'aime beaucoup !
Ha c'est des émotions quand même tout ça !
Donc ça la vidéo avec la première arrivée de Kemar dedans !
Hé tu fais quoi ?
Kemar ! Il est présent avec nous !
On voulait se reformer pour commenter ensemble une petite vidéo du Velcrou !
YES !
Donc Marcelin, bien sûr mon premier rôle !
Ouais ?
Ce gars-là est plus que baisable !
L'homme hideux !
Allez bonsoir !
Enorme love !
Bon appétit ! Bon appétit !
Donc "Les aventures du Velcrou" c'était une sorte de petite websérie qu'on avait faite
Putain j'arrête pas de penser à Jean-Pierre ! J'ai des hallu..
Donc Jean-Pierre c'était notre poisson rouge
Ouais moi aussi il me manque..
Il me manque depuis que je l'ai tué..
Quoi ?!
Enfin non, je ne l'ai pas tué...
Pardon ?! Qu'est-ce que tu as dit putain ?!
Ha oui ! C'est génial ça !
Mais j'ai pas fait exprès ! Non, c''est pas ce que tu crois !
Ha oui alors là !
Y'a mon putain de reflet dans le truc !
On voit Hugo qui cadre dans le reflet derrière !
C'est génial !
Voilà ! Et moi on voit mes pieds !
On voit mes pieds dans le reflet..
Ha mais le niveau quoi..
Kiwi arrête toi ! J'ai un truc à te dire !
Kiwi.. Je viens du futur !
C'était avant Le visiteur du futur !
Et ça c'était la raison de notre nom
Exact !
Le Velcrou ! Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'on avait des chaussures à Velcro !
Voilà ! Tous les deux on portait des chaussures à velcro
C'était un peu stylé à l'époque !
Mais qu'est-ce qu'il se passe ?!
Oh nan !
Genre les effets spéciaux !
"Attention virus" ! C'est Paint !
Alors cette vidéo c'était il y a 7 ans !
Ça s'appelle Cinq Etoiles
Cinq étoiles c'était en rapport aux étoiles qu'on mettait sur les vidéos Dailymotion
264 000 vues quand même !
Et le son c'est moi qui l'ai fait ! J'tiens à le préciser, j'en suis fier !
Je me rappelle de ces trucs là !
On était totalement refaits quoi !
C'est clair !
C'était la première fois qu'on avait des petits trucs comme ça en incruste !
C'était Morgan Préleur qui les avait fait !
Noside !
Dédicade Noside !
Cinq Étoiles !
J'me rappelle les gens disaient "Ouais tu rap bien et tout"
Nan mais ça va, c'est pas mal là !
Abonne toi au RSS !
C'était vraiment à l'époque du CD-Rom quoi !
C'est que des bons souvenirs !
C'était vraiment très sympa !
Je propose qu'on regarde une toute dernière vidéo !
Ouais !
Ça s'appelait le "Techto" !
Donc c'était à l'époque de la Techtonik !
Moi je trouvais ça classe ma veste..
Un techto c'est comme un texto mais en version techtonik !
Et là ça part en mode dynamique attention !
Avec derrière mon drap pour dormir !
Oh mais la galère !
C'était mon plaid !
Ha énorme ! Je ne connaissais pas !
Quel acteur !
Répondre, envoyer un techto !
C'est parti !
C'est tellement long putain !
En plus je me rappelle : t'étais un peu en mode "ouais j'danse bien et tout"
N'importe quoi !
C'est pas vrai !
Genre quand je faisais ça là
Putain j'suis stylé, j'suis beau goss !
Attends, franchement ça se voit dans ton visage frère !
Mais n'importe quoi !
Le Velcrou ! Premier sur le Techto !
Regarde les portables pas cadrés !
Ils n'étaient pas du tout dans le cadre ! Merde, merde..
Ha on s'est bien marrés là !
On a bien rigolé !
J'en ai pleuré !
Merci Internet ! Merci la vie ! Merci Hugo Dessioux !
Un câlin avec des casques c'est pas pratique attention !
Vraiment ça m'a ému, ça m'a fait plaisir..
Mais ça m'a aussi donné un énorme coup de vieux !
Nan c'était bien cool ! Des bonnes vieilles vidéos !
Mais y'a des gens qui regardent ça encore tu crois ?
Heu apparemment j'ai eu un message : apparemment non.
Ils ont envoyé un message : personne ne regarde vos vidéos
Y'a un mec qui a envoyé un message : heu ...
Je ne regarde pas vos vidéos je vous le dis !
Bon j'ai refait ta blague mais en bafouillant
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo !
Un peu particulière, un rétrospective !
Ça m'a bien fait marré !
Et puis surtout c'était un peu émouvant mine de rien !
Ça fait 9 ans que je fais mes vidéos sur Internet
Ça peut paraître rien pour certains, mais pour moi c'est toute ma vie
J'adore faire ça !
J'évolue avec mes vidéos, je grandis, et ça j'y peux rien !
Mine de rien j'évolue aussi dans mon style et c'est la vie c'est comme ça !
A très bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo ! Et comme dirait le moi de l'époque :
Ciao !